today in America there is 1.7 trillion
dollars of student debts
people should have access to Quality
education
for a reasonable amount of money
this is the case in all European
countries this is the case in many Asian
countries it's in like most countries
actually
you know sometimes most ideas are ideas
searching for a problem and we're a
problem searching for decades for a
solution
our goal the mission of Moses to tear
down all Financial barriers to
opportunity to everyone
[Music]
I'm Amir ayawi and I'm the founder of
Mars
I was born and raised in Tunisia I grew
up in Tunisia under a dictatorship at
that time I was very active when I was
young against the dictatorship and was
part of the Arabs right
I was one of those who started these
like social movements online says
blogger I was on Twitter
talking about like human rights abuses
in my country
at the time I was definitely one of the
youngest activists out there so one day
I was kidnapped in the street and threw
out of the borders and made my way to
Europe
so I lived in France I worked illegally
for all sorts of underpaid jobs like dog
sittings babysitting anything sitting
basically
in 2011 Tunisia became a democracy and I
felt like my job was done what I owe my
country was done and that's how I
decided to jump into my next chapter
and I moved to the US in 2018 so when I
came here to San Francisco
um it was like spending a lot of time
with Uber drivers talking to them and to
their families to understand like if you
can fix anything in the world what would
you fix for them it was
how can I make sure that my children
have a better future than mine and this
is where it was so interesting to go dig
deep into what does that mean and that's
how actually Moss started
Moss is a financial app that helps you
tear down Financial barriers to
opportunity
the idea of mass is how do you take
those Financial Solutions that are built
for the one percent and make them
accessible to the 99 what is incredible
in this country is that the cost of
college is like flight tickets
you can be sitting here paying two
hundred dollars the person next to you
is paying 1 000 at the next person next
to you is paying zero and so Moss's job
is to make you the person who's paying
zero
responses Moss has a set of financial
features that helps you with the biggest
financial problems you will face in your
first years of adulting and we attack
the problem of college tuition through
two ways one by making colleges asking
you for less and two by getting you the
maximum free money you're eligible for
one of the most incredible things we do
is that Mouse has the biggest
scholarship pool in America we have over
160 billion dollars of financial aid and
this is the place for scholarship we
have like a ton of scholarship but what
is good is why I open my MOS account
they know for example that Moss knows
already that I'm a Hispanic student and
that I come from Texas so instead of me
being lost into the 160 billion dollars
of scholarship that Moss has has for
everybody I have the ones that I know
will be good for me I have the high
chance taxes grants they're all here
some like ten thousand dollars three
thousand dollars three thousand dollars
ten thousand dollars and I can just like
go and apply the other thing that we
have at Mars is that we actually give
you cash back on applying for
scholarships
we actually helped you get money by
getting you jobs through our gigs
platform so we work with gig Partners
who are looking for students and pay
students well and we connect you with us
people think it's crazy that the
financial app gives you free money or a
bank gives you free money we're very
different from what's in there
I am absolutely Amazed by the work that
has been done by all the activists who
are fighting every day to get people to
fit our future a better education access
to education I believe that that is like
the ultimate goal is that we do not let
people borrow insane amount of money
than them big for beg for a savior to
come and give that money to them back
nearly 45 percent can have their student
debt fully cancel
that's 20 million people who can start
getting on with their lives
there is a true business potential
potential and believing in the 99
and making them better
making them earn more
by earner more they will spend more by
earning more they will enjoy life more
by earning more they will enjoy the
solution you gave them more
and so if you think about it just from a
business perspective that is already
like a win-win I'm absurdly optimistic I
really do believe things can change I
believe that the future can be bright
I'm someone that wakes up happy uh in
the morning and so I think
I I always think about like the biggest
problems in a positive mindset and that
keeps me going